wir wollen jetzt diese schrecklichen
terrortaten weiter ein ort mit dem
terrorismus experten peter neumann denn
jetzt live zugeschaltet des guten abend
herr neumann islamistischen kalender ist
heute der geburtstag des propheten
glauben sie da an einen zufall oder
wurde dieser tag bewusst gewählt es kann
durchaus sein dass das bewusst gewählt
wurde
dieses hat ja in der vergangenheit
gesagt man soll zu religiösen feiertagen
anschläge wird üben busines auch das
andere anschläge in der vergangenheit an
bestimmten tagen erfolgt sind also zumal
wenn man ganz weit zurück denkt die
anschläge in madrid am 11
am 11 märz 2004 genau dreieinhalb jahren
soweit es vielleicht ist das kein zufall
es kann durchaus so sein dass der abend
hätte sich dieses datum genau ausgesucht
vielleicht können sie uns ein bisschen
weiter erklären warum trifft es immer
wieder frankreich also paris-nizza wurde
ja auch schon öfter ziel solcher
terroranschläge erinnern uns an den 14
juli nationalfeiertag von frankreich wo
ein mann ein terrorist mit einem lkw in
eine menschenmenge gerast und 86
menschen dort starben und zuletzt jetzt
im oktober der fall wo ein lehrer auf
offener straße enthauptet wurde warum
trifft es immer wieder frankreich das
ist natürlich hängt mit verschiedenen
faktoren zusammen ich glaube schon dass
es in frankreich eine noch härtere und
stärkere auseinandersetzung gibt
zwischen muslimischen gemeinschaften und
dem start einen start in frankreich dir
noch kompromissloser und wehrhafte es
wenn es um die verteidigung das was die
franzosen laizismus nennen also eine
sehr aggressive formen des säkularismus
und natürlich gibt es in frankreich auch
ganz erhebliche spannungen aktuell
liegen der situation aber eben auch
schon seit jahrzehnten eine fast völlige
segregation der verschiedenen
populationen im land und viel hasse auch
aufeinander
und das ist etwas was ich immer wieder
zeigt und ich glaube auch dass
frankreich von dieser welle wenn es denn
eine welle ist stärker betroffen sein
wird als zb deutschland auch in
deutschland gibt es natürlich ein
problem
ich glaube in frankreich ist dieser
auseinandersetzung hat er nochmal
brutaler als in jedem anderen
europäischen land
das wäre jetzt meine nächste frage
gewesen weil frankreich auch so nah an
uns dran liegt wie hoch schätzen sie die
gefahr für deutschland ein dass solche
taten oder ähnliche taten bei uns hier
passieren können die können stets
passieren und es ist natürlich ein
fehler zu glauben dass mit dem
niedergang des sogenannten islamischen
staates 2017 dass damit die
islamistische gefahr plötzlich aufgehört
hätte die hat nicht aufgehört ganz im
gegenteil wenn sie so wollen der virus
dem der es nach europa getragen hat der
existiert und ist immer noch virulent in
vielen islamistischen populationen
überall in europa und gerade nach
solchen anschlägen ist die
sicherheitsgefahr immer erhöhen
den attentäter wollten zum einen
natürlich die gesellschaft erpressen sie
wollen der gesellschaft angst einjagen
aber sie wollen auch eigene anhänger die
leute die auf der eigenen seite stehen
zum weiteren taten ermutigen sie wollen
quasi ein signal setzen und das sehen
wir auch in vielen islamistischen
kanälen in den sozialen medien aktuell
dass gesagt wird hier ist das beispiel
ihr solltet jetzt bitte nach und
deswegen das sind die
sicherheitsbehörden auch in deutschland
richtige reisen momentan ganz besonders
sensibilisiert auf dieses thema weil
genau nach diesen anstieg immer die
gefahr besteht dass leute nachfolgen
und in frankreich gilt jetzt die höchste
terrorwarnstufe vielleicht können sie
uns das genauer erklären was genau
bedeutet das jetzt also frankreich
genauso wie auch zb in großbritannien wo
ich ohne gibt es ein system mit
verschiedenen terror warnstufen die
gefahrenstufe in frankreich ist momentan
im sommer also das ist die höchste
terror warnstufe das bedeutet mehr
polizei auf der straße deutlich mehr
ressourcen der französischen
sicherheitsbehörden werden in diesem
bereich gezogen mehr beobachtungen es
wird niederschwellig niederschwelliger
beobachtet und es wird im prinzip an
jeder schraube gedreht die den
sicherheitsrat um steht und ich erwarte
auch dass wir in den nächsten tagen noch
mal mehr festnahmen sehen werden und
dass der französische staat ganz
deutlich machen wird das im prinzip
keine form von islamismus mehr gibt und
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei der schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren